Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Sci-fi drama film
called “Hashtag.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
In the near future, social media has become
a subject of world dominance and social media
celebrities have an immense influence on our
culture. The commoners follow them blindly and buy
whatever product they endorse and consume. Such
media influencers sell their lives on the internet
to a level that they have no privacy. Their main
motto is to not lose followers and they are ready
to go to extreme lengths to achieve that. One
of such influencers is a young woman named X.
X lives in a tiny futuristic room that serves as
her workplace, lounging area, and her bedroom.
At the beginning of the movie, she is in front
of a futuristic AI computer that displays her
followers reacting to her content. They come and
go so quickly that X has to reply to more than
fifty interactions per minute. An AI personnel
named Te’a helps her by posting the comments on
her command and walking her through the activities
of the day. Every few minutes, Te’a reminds X to
upload a status. Most of the time, X throws
in some inspirational quotes which get more
than a hundred million likes. In her recent
status, she advises her followers to know and
love what they’re doing for success. The status
alone gets one hundred and four million likes.
Te’a tells X when to stop working for the day.
It is clear that X doesn’t have much control
over her life but she is too busy counting
her followers to notice. Her daily progress
is displayed on the screen which says that she
has gained more than a million followers in
just one day making her followers count closer to
hitting a billion. She was mentioned twenty-seven
million times per minute, she received four
billion likes and nineteen million dislikes,
and her annual subscriber revenue is a whopping
nine and a half trillion dollars. The computer
finally shuts off and she takes a sigh of relief.
Te’a again asks for her status and she recites
yet another motivational quote. More than a
hundred million people like the update instantly.
Even after getting off the computer, X is still
working. There is a cluster of cameras fitted on
the ceiling to her room that live streams her life
to millions of special subscribers at all times.
People pay millions of dollars to watch
her change clothes, sleep, read her emails,
and so on. Her work desk automatically slides
underground and her bed emerges from the floor,
indicating it is her time to sleep.
She takes her clothes off to go to bed
when Te’a announces that there are two
hundred and four million subscribers
watching her currently. The following morning,
X wakes up to gentle rain patting on her window.
She gets up and immediately submits her
early morning status on Te’a’s request.
X then takes a picture of herself, edits it
heavily, and posts it on the internet. When
she gets off the bed, she is completely naked. Her
body is censored to some of the followers who are
told to upgrade their subscription to get the full
view. When it’s time for her to shower, a shower
room automatically arises in a corner of the
room. Even in the shower, three hundred million
premium subscribers are allowed to watch her. She
takes a picture with her body wash which increases
its sales by a lot. However, X’s subscriber
count goes downhill because of her next status
in which she implies that it is impossible
to argue with women. X quickly asks Te’a to
take a picture of her body while showering
and posts it to all of her followers. This
doubles the count of new subscribers and
her status recovers again. X then requests
her followers to vote for her on famous.com to
make her the greatest influencer of all time.
Along with the request, she
attaches a nude picture of her.
When it is time for her to get ready for the day,
the room creates an automated wardrobe for her.
She simply asks the AI for a blue dress. The
command triggers a drone who flies around X
and creates a tailor-fitted dress according to her
wish. It also chooses appropriate accessories for
her and makes her look pretty for the followers.
Because of her influence, the sales of the blue
dress increases exponentially. As she is taking
pictures for the tenth time this morning,
she receives her mails. On peeking through the
looking hole, she sees an empty hallway outside.
It is time for her to check into work so she
ignores the mails for the time being. Suddenly,
her computer screen goes black and a message
saying “do you question” flashes instead of the
comments. The screen goes back to normal in only
a few seconds so X doesn’t think much of it. But
without her noticing, an envelope that she just
received in the mail starts glowing. As X goes
through the day, she eats all her meals in front
of the computer, promoting them for followers.
Some hours later, Te’a announces that it is
X’s time to relax. She gets only a ten-minute
break throughout the day. For the break, she
can choose a program from their computerized
vacationing subscription. She gets to choose to go
to a virtual beach, party, spa, and others. While
shuffling through the options, she gets a papercut
from the envelope in her hand. She doesn’t think
much of it and continues shuffling. The beach
seems a viable option but the people there
are her fans who cannot stop gushing over her
presence, so she skips them. What she doesn’t
notice is a strange man being formed on his own
in the background. Moments later, she stops to
watch a firework display and is enjoying it until
the man from the beach starts walking towards her.
She feels uncomfortable and skips again but
the man is also present in the next program.
He asks her if she questions her life or
just goes along with it. X is too scared to
understand what he means. She retreats as the man
crosses the barrier and somehow enters her room.
He raises his hands to touch her and the
contact gives rise to sparks of electricity.
The man disappears right after but he has provided
X with the ability to understand her reality.
Moments later, she composes herself and opens
the envelope for the first time. Inside is a
tablet that says “question everything”. When she
turns it around, the tablet asks her if her cage
exists. She tries to comprehend what it means
and realizes that she has never been out of
her room which might mean that it is her cage.
She walks up to her door and leans down on it,
but because of her earlier interaction with the
guy, the stimulation doesn’t work on her and she
falls to the other side. The horrifying
truth of her life is then revealed to X.
It turns out that she is being used as a worker
by a multi-million dollar influencer company
that keeps them trapped in a tiny box in a
factory. She has been trapped and has been lied
to about her life. Similar to her, the company
cages thousands of influencers and uses them for
their own good. X quickly runs back to her room
and looks at the tablet again. Te’a announces
that her break time is completed so she will have
to update her status soon. When X doesn’t answer,
Te’a warns her of the consequences if she doesn’t
update her status. X cannot differentiate between
the illusions and reality around her.
Just then, the rain outside her window
starts to glitch. Te’a informs her that failing to
update her status is a violation of the celebrity
franchise handbook. Having had enough of the
lies, X asks Te’a if she is in a cage. Te’a
misunderstands X’s question for status and claims
that a question is an invalid status according to
the handbook. X yet again asks her if is in a
cage. Instead of answering, the machine replies
that all of her subscribers have left the room
and she has no followers now. X quickly tries to
recover and takes her clothes off to show off her
body and regain the followers. But the strategy
doesn’t work this time. She desperately tries to
take a seductive picture but Te’a stops answering.
Following that, three men enter the room and drag
X outside as she retaliates. When she wakes up,
X is in a hospital bed being taken care
of by a machine. The door opens and two
doctors enter the doom. Doctor Mitchell is
happy because X is her last eval of the day.
They look at her report and find out that X’s
real name is Alexandra. They ask X for status but
she takes her time to reply. Because of the lag,
they diagnose that her speech and response time
are lagging. She had been working for twenty-two
hours and the last sleep she had was around four
hours. The doctors believe that her sleep cycle
is the root of the problem. As they discuss this,
X doesn’t respond with anything. She has a hard
time grasping reality. All of a sudden, she claims
that she has eight hundred million subscribers
but the doctor informs her they are all gone. They
call her old and believe that she is no longer
of service to the company. X starts to freak out
because her followers’ count is the only thing
she has cared about until now. She insists that
she is loved by her fans. However, the doctors
declare that it is her time to retire now.
The second doctor, Gil, finally shows his
face and reveals that he is the guy who met
X earlier in her room. He calms a frantic
X and leaves the room. Before leaving,
doctor Mitchell comments about the increasing
number of crasher cases in the influencers.
One can assume that doctor Gil doesn’t agree
with the company’s values and is rescuing the
influencers, one after another. In the last
scene, a screen appears before X welcoming
her to the internet as a consumer.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.